my favorite of course being deborah
messing
debra messing played grace on the 90s
sitcom will and grace
to my knowledge that's the last thing
she ever did but for some reason
she's a blue checkmark and she still
spats off about politics and people
still listen to her
debra messing shows you just how out for
blood
the left is they just they hate trump
they want to punish him after he leaves
office which i hope happens in four
years
or eight years or 12 years or i don't
know 16 years but
it's looking more likely that it will be
sooner than that so
debra messing initially tweets out she
says
that she hopes that president trump
becomes the most popular
boyfriend in prison
you see this is because he'll go to a
prison and
there'll only be men in this prison and
that he'll be
i assume he won't become a homosexual
overnight
so he'll be probably you know preyed
upon
by these these predators in prison
that's that's the implication right
but debra messing because she's a left
winger always has to pay lip service to
how she's
pro lgbt lmnop
she's an ally she loves all these sorts
of different
sexual uh preferences and behaviors and
so
her tweet sounded to use a popular word
homophobic right because you're saying i
hope you're the most popular boyfriend
but trump's not a homosexual so
what's that mean well she had she
clarified it okay
so she issued this apology quote let me
be clear
i said nothing about q i lgbtqi
queer slash queer what's the q
there's already a q in there there's two
queers who knows
love i didn't say anything about that
love rape is an act of violence
trump has perpetrated violence on
hundreds of millions of people my hope
is and it's the first time in my life
that the tables are turned and he is the
victim of perpetrators
hashtag lgbtqia
ally well there's another letter in
there than there was in the first
acronym whatever
or the first initialism you see
deborah messing was not in any way
hoping that president trump would
participate in consensual
homosexual love she's hoping he'll get
raped by a man by a gay guy
she wants just to clear it up because
she's an ally to the gay
lgbtq community what and i know maybe
she didn't use the right choice of words
she's hoping that a gay inmate
rapes the president of the united states
which is uh that's obviously so much
better
hope this clears it up she wasn't making
a homophobic
comment she was making light of rape
a ally hashtag love wins hashtag love
trump's hate
hashtag deborah messing hopes the
president of the united states gets
raped
by a homosexual convict
she deleted that one that one didn't
didn't play very very well it sort of
like just digging that hole making
matters worse so then
she issued another apology try it again
quote i'd like to say that i have been
an lgbtqia
ally for decades so she added the first
time she said she was the
she liked all the throats of love she
didn't have the a but now she has the a
again you know maybe the third apology
she'll have another lighter in there
i was in no way referencing lgbtqi
queer no no more a love slash sexuality
okay yeah i think she already mentioned
that right it is not my proudest moment
but 45 his victim
victimized hundreds of millions of
people i had wished the tables turned on
him
i apologize for the offensive way i did
it
so huh
so so she's not
referencing anything having to do with
homosexuality or anything like that
um she is still hoping that he is raped
by an inmate because she still wants him
to be in prison
but not by a same-sex inmate not by a
male inmate
not by a gay inmate so she wants
if i'm understanding this correctly
deborah messing wants the president of
the united states
to go to prison and i
get maybe a mult a a prison with men and
women at it i don't think there are many
of those but
anyway assuming he goes to a regular
prison she wants the president to be
raped
by a woman who
sneaks into the prison it wouldn't be a
conjugal visit because that of course
would be consensual
so she wants a woman to sneak into a
male prison
and rape the president sorry for any
confusion that she's caused
i you know i mean all jokes aside she
obviously has an extraordinarily
incoherent view of sex and love and
politics and everything else
the left no i guess they don't really
take sexual assault seriously i was
going to say that they take it seriously
because they talk about me too you know
the campus rape epidemic where they say
one in four women
at harvard yard are raped you know on
college campuses as though
the american university campuses is more
dangerous than fallujah or something
obviously ridiculous but they don't take
it seriously right i mean if
if the left took sexual assault and rape
seriously
they would want those crimes to be
prosecuted by the criminal justice
system
they would want the perpetrators of
those crimes to face real consequences
face trial and then go to prison but
that's not what they do but they set up
these ridiculous tribunals on university
campuses where professors decide to
expel
students because of these but they never
face any actual criminal justice
they never actually face trials or
anything like that they go to the me too
and they get some director fired or
something
they never really with a few exceptions
they never push for them to
to have justice because they don't they
don't take this seriously